to me this this whole experience there  was not a dry eye in the audience on  Monday during night one of the Dancing  with the Stars finale following bindi  Irwin 'he's beautiful freestyle dance  paying tribute to her late father Steve  Irwin I never really talked about  everything that I felt when Dad passed  away but I never thought that I'd  revisit that sometimes sharing your  hustles it feels like there's three  people in the room  [Music]  [Applause]  after performing and earning a perfect  30 out of 30 it was revealed bindi had  no idea the photo with her dad would  appear on screen it was a special  surprise from Derek physics time  experience has changed my life